[Music]
virgin is becoming used to The Sight and
Sound of rail Strikers on picket lines
today their largest movement yet members
of all four rail unions are staging a
simultaneous walkout for the first time
as they continue to call for a pay rise
in line with inflation and a halt to job
Cuts as well as plan changes to working
hours
the first group owns the railway they
own this Railway that I'm standing
outside now eventually West Coast they
are creaming in money they don't want to
play the game and what they want to do
is extract that from Railway workers
they also want to milk the public
its action that continues to derail
people's plans this family traveled from
Oslo to see a Liverpool game only to
find out about the strikes on the last
leg of their Journey try to get the Uber
or a coach or
maybe stay in London I don't know and
how are you guys feeling it's sad to
miss the football
yeah
strikes from the summer of discontent
have now spilled over into the Autumn
the rail dispute has lasted months of a
ballot of its members set to take place
next week as you can see behind me
the wave of industrial action still has
plenty of support because our strength
is our organization our strength is our
Unity that support including a familiar
campaigning voice as they are as well as
a fictional face too helping to
represent Royal Mail workers
they're striking for 21 days over the
next few months with similar demands
overpay
disruption on the railways presents a
hurdle for people competing in the
London Marathon
many will now struggle to make the start
line tomorrow but the people striking
say their issue isn't with the public
but those in power as they target the
Conservative Party Conference
new transport secretary Anne Marie
trevelyn says she'll try to compromise
failing to find a middle ground could
see walkouts continue into the middle of
next dish